If you do your best to observe 13.8 billion light years away, you can
still see the big
bang
happening.
Thisis
SpaceSupport
[Music]
First question is Mr. Funyo, there
are more stars in space than grains of sand on earth.
[Music] It
's kind of hard to count how many grains of sand there are on Earth, but if you're
limited to grains of sand that can be seen by the human eye, there are
far more stars than stars.
There might be a lot of Tsums that you can't see,
so the
answer might be different depending on how
far you count them.  It's
because the
universe had a beginning. It's
13.8 billion years old since the beginning of the universe.  This
is the reason why the night sky is not bright because
the universe had a beginning.  The constellations are
also
changing rapidly, so when you
look up at the night sky after 1,000 years, the
shapes of the constellations will all look different.  The
next question is me, Mika-san.I
heard that outer space is a vacuum state without air,
or is it filled with some kind of substance
?In fact,
outer space is not a vacuum even in places where there seems to be nothing, it
is dark.
Our galaxy is filled with an unknown substance called matter. I thought that our galaxy was just a collection of stars,
but actually, this
dark matter, a
sea of ​​dark matter, is filled with
stars.  It is
believed that there is a lot of dark matter in the space between the stars, even in what appears to be nothing.
And this dark matter is actually our
mother.  I would love to
meet you someday. Next question is Mr. Chicken B.
Why does space explode and generate heat when there is no air?
When something burns, it's true that it doesn't burn without oxygen,
but
when something explodes in outer space,
heat is generated in a different way than when something burns.
When the nuclei in the nucleus stick together,
much more
energy is released than when a normal thing burns. Surprisingly, the weight is
converted into energy and
exploded, so
even in outer space where there is no air and no oxygen  This
method allows things to burn and explode,
and the fragments from the explosion of a star
are the source of your body. You are
actually from outer space.
If the
size of our galaxy is my size, how
big is the galaxy
?  The
next question is Mr. Azuki. Do you
think it will be possible to observe the outer part of the universe where we live in the future?  In the
universe, we
can only see light that has reached us over the course of 13.8 billion
years, so we can only see 13.8 billion light-years
worth of light, right?  We
may be able to see it, but the truth
is that the expansion of the universe is gradually accelerating,
so I'm a little worried that the places we can see now will
gradually disappear.
What we do know about size is that we can measure how curved the universe is.  In other words,
if you draw a large triangle on the Earth, the
sum of the interior angles is actually larger than 180 degrees, unlike what you learn at school.  If you
draw a large triangle in the universe and measure the sum of the interior angles, it's
almost 180 degrees, but it
might be a little larger.  I
know that it is big, but I
don't know if it's really big. Next question: Is
it possible?
What was there in space before the universe was created
? Was there space in the first place?
No one really knows what happened to Big Man. At
present, people think that there was no space or time before the Big Bang happened.  It's
expanding,
but it's
not like there was already space beyond that to listen to.
That
's my current way of thinking, and even if I ask what lies beyond that, it's
still the universe that lies there.  Now I'm
thinking about the next question, Mr. Fuso Yamashiro.
Why do you know that there was a
big
bang?  If you
try your best to observe the
big bang, you can still see it
happening.
That's why we're dressed like this ball. We're
inside of it. And depending on the
angle from which you look at it, the
temperature is slightly different, so I made
this picture of the Big Bang with a
great exaggeration.  This is the part where our
galaxy shines brightly, so
please forget about it. All the other parts are
light from the big bang that finally arrived after 13.8 billion years.
So the
next question is, Mr. Keita, do you know what the first star was born
? Actually, the universe started with the big bang, and
after that, the heat of the big bang
disappeared and no stars were born yet.  It's
thought that there was a time when stars didn't shine, and that time lasted for hundreds of millions of years.  It is
believed that various first insects were born in every universe, but we haven't been able to observe them yet.  I
think that I might be able to see something like this, and I am still grateful, so I
think that eventually there will be reports that feel that this is the first star.  Does it
exist?
Of course we
don't know whether it exists or not, but it's said that it wouldn't be strange.  There
is a theory that there are so many parallel words.The reason why I'm thinking about that is
that when I look at the current
universe, it's Dekisugi, is
n't it?  It's
just too much work, so there's a theory that the universe is just a clumsy gun.  I
have a way of thinking, so people
think it's okay to have a
parallel world.  The question of
whether or not there is a
possibility of annihilation can be proved here and now, and it probably wouldn't have
been strange for the same thing to have happened elsewhere.  I
can't imagine that this universe will prove it right now.  If you do, you'll
end up with a different universe that doesn't even look like the current universe, and
eventually that universe will stop expanding and collapse again.
Well, I don't think there's anything to worry about for the time being.Is
there a star with a pungent taste and an enormous size that has a stronger gravitational pull than a
black hole?
Black folios also have stars with strong gravitational pull,
but they are also black holes.
We also know that
there are black holes that
weigh billions of times more than the sun.  The reason is that the
size of the black hole is the
size of the heavy black hole, which is large, so they are separated, so the
gravity at that location is actually
small for the large black hole.  If you
look for a small black hole and
fall into it, you can experience it.
Blackrone observes it all
the time, and
sometimes it glows dimly. What's happening is that gas that happens to pass by is being
dragged by the gravity of the black hole,
becoming hot, and
emitting a death scream.
Of course, if you go inside, you
won't be able to see anything because there won't be any light or anything coming out.  The
next question is, Mr. Melon, when I often
check whether there are life forms other than the earth, I
look for habits that are likely to be inhabited by life forms with elements such as water and oxygen.  However, in the first place,
organisms that require oxygen and water
may only exist on Earth, and organisms on other planets may
not have other elements.
This is a good question, and if there were
life that was completely different from the life we ​​live on the earth, then maybe there would
be such a life even without water and oxygen.  No,
but as far as we know, if we
think about these living things made of atoms, we
can scientifically research the properties of the molecules that bind them together, so if there is no water,
nutrients will circulate inside the body.
Without oxygen, it is probably impossible to absorb various things and
activate the body, so it is
thought that oxygen and water are
probably necessary.  I don't know why, so maybe
there are living things that can live without oxygen and water,
but I
think they probably need oxygen and water, so I'm
looking for a planet that seems to have oxygen and liquid water.
So the next
question is Mr. Takamen. I heard that
if you move at a speed very close to high speed, time will flow very slowly.
Can you actually
travel to a distant star for a few days? Yes, that's right.  If you
keep moving
around, you might think that you've really done it in just a
few days.
If you come, you're literally
Taro Urashima.
So, when you fly close to the speed of light, time
slows down. This
is a fact that has been experimentally observed.
Warp is
like a shortcut in space, but it's
not like you can warp on your own.  Assuming
that
is a flat object like this, if it is
folded like this, there
might be a shortcut when going from this universe to here.  It
means that we have warped, so from here we can go straight along the universe with a
shortcut rather than an attack.  I do
n't
think I can do it, so unfortunately I don't think I can
do the warp that is convenient for me.
I have a
question. Matter is sometimes a part of a star,
other times it is a map of life, and it seems that it
circulates.  Is it possible that a small amount of matter
changes from time to time? The universe has already
become quite cold,
so sudden production and disappearance of matter rarely occurs.  When they
collide, a pair of matter and
antimatter is formed, and the antimatter that has formed
meets the matter around it and disappears,
annihilating itself.
However, the current universe is cold enough that the
shipping cost of matter is thought to be almost constant.  To
what extent do you
think we can elucidate the
universe
?
Other than that, maybe it's
dark matter, the
substance of our mother's path, but I
really want to
meet you.  I
think that many things have been elucidated,
but I think that it is still possible to understand everything
by the end of the 21st century.
What's the attraction,
in my opinion, to
know the universe is to know yourself,
because our bodies are
born from the dust of a star that exploded long ago in space, so
our home is the
universe.  To know where we came from,
what kind of person we are, and what will happen to us in
the future.
As you can see,
space is actually your
hometown, so
when you think about space, think about yourself as well.
People of 100 million years are
crowded together, and they often fight and
destroy their beautiful homes.So when you
look at it from the outside, you can see that we all get along
well and really think that we have to take care of this earth.  I
think that if you look at the earth from space, your daily thoughts will change. So,
did you enjoy learning about the universe and learning about yourself? Thank you very much.
[Music]